what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down some of the strongest
quirks in my hero academia I will be
examining their unique powers their
strengths their weaknesses and their
potential just to be clear this is not
an exhaustive list or a countdown this
is an analysis of what I believe to be
some of the strongest and most
overpowered quirks in boku no hero
having said that if there are other opie
quirks that you would like to see me
cover in a future video just leave a
like subscribe and write your
suggestions down in the comments if we
can hit 4,000 likes on this video I will
make a part 2 that features your
suggested quirks you can also hit me up
on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar with your
suggestions
finally this video will contain boku no
hero manga spoilers I will be using all
of the latest information that we have
about the quirks that I will be
mentioning so please proceed with
caution you have been warned first up
let's talk about one of the most
important quirks in the entire story
the quirk used by the legendary symbol
of peace all minds and a quirk currently
being used by the main character of the
story is Akuma Doria aka Deku I'm of
course talking about the epic quirk
Popoff I mean I mean one for all one for
all is a unique transferable quirk that
was possessed by seven other people in
the past before being possessed by all
might the eighth user and then
eventually Deku the ninth and current
user as we eventually learn one for all
is not a naturally occurring quirk
rather it is an accidental fusion of two
previously separate quirks
a quirk that stockpiles power and a
quirk that allows quirks to be willingly
transferred from one person to another
the stockpiling side of one for all
gives its users superhuman strength
reflexes stamina agility and speed as we
learned from all might after he
transferred one for all to Deku once the
quirk is transferred from one person to
another
the one who transfers it can still make
use of some leftover embers of the quark
although these embers will eventually
run out the stockpiled power that the
user of one-for-all has access to can be
channeled into a particular part of the
body or spread out throughout the whole
body focusing more power into one body
part such as an arm or a leg will put
more strain on that part of the body in
particular this body strain is
especially severe at first before the
user learns to control the power of the
quark and as we saw with Deku using the
quark without experience can lead to
broken fingers arms and legs but
eventually once the user learns to
control the quark he or she can learn to
control the percentage of the quarks
power that they are using at any given
time which helps to minimize the strain
one-for-all has an inner cord that has
gotten increasingly stronger as the
quark has been passed on from one user
to another which makes sense for a
stockpiling quark however as the story
goes on we eventually learned that as
one for all is being passed on from one
person to another the quark factor of
each user merges with the core of the
quark this unusual process has been
repeating for many generations and now
Deku the ninth one for all user is
slowly gaining the ability to manifest
the quirks of the previous one for all
users what's more these quirks have been
amplified by one for all stockpiling
power which means that Deku will
eventually have access to six new quirks
and these quirks will be even stronger
than they were back when they were
possessed by their original users so far
Deku has been able to reliably manifest
one of the six works and that quirk is
called black whip this quirk allows its
user to generate powerful black whips
from his body and these whips can be
used to grab things and people and also
to maneuver around more easily deck who
wasn't able to use the whips effectively
at first and he needed to practice and
train before he could make effective use
of this new quirk according to all might
and gran torino the next quirk that Deku
is going to be manifesting is float the
quirk that was possessed by all mites
former master Nana Shimura this quirk
allowed Nana to essentially float
through the air and potentially even fly
at will although we're not yet sure how
exactly the quirk works since we still
haven't seen it in action
the true workings of one for all have
been a major mystery throughout the
story and although we have gotten a lot
more information about it as the story
has continued to develop it is likely
that there are even more mysteries that
one for all is hiding we all remember
how Deku was able to break through Shin
hos mind-control thanks to the unique
properties of one for all and who knows
what other secret one-for-all may still
be hiding by its very nature one for all
is a quirk that continues to get
stronger as time goes on and it also
gets stronger as it is passed on from
one user to the next so initially one
for all was not one of the strongest
quirks in the world and it was certainly
not stronger than all for one but one
for all did have one advantage over all
for one one for all can only be
transferred from one user to another
willingly it cannot be stolen against
the users will and this makes it
impossible for all for one to forcibly
take it and as one for all has been
passed on from generation to generation
it eventually became just as strong and
arguably even stronger than all for one
all might the eighth user of one for all
was able to become the number one pro
hero because of the power of the quirk
and he was eventually able to defeat all
for one on two separate occasions and of
course we see that deck who even as a
student who is still learning to master
one for all is able to defeat much more
experienced villains like muscular and
gentle on his own all thanks to one for
all so overall one for all is without a
doubt one of the strongest quirks in
boku no hero
the feats we've seen accomplished by
both Almighty and Deku through the use
of one for all demonstrate how strong
this quirk truly is and the fact that
the quirk is continuing to grow and
evolve means that we can expect it to
just keep getting stronger and stronger
especially now that the current user
Deku is going to manifest up to six
other useful quirks on top of one for
all
to be fair one for all definitely has
some drawbacks such as the fact that
until the quirk is mastered it will
cause serious damage to the user's body
but both Almighty and deku have proven
that with rigorous training the
drawbacks of the quirk can be mitigated
next up let's talk about the polar
opposite of one for all the sinister
quirks stealing all for one all for one
allows its user to steal the quirks of
others and then use those quirks himself
and this includes combining multiple
quirks inside one person to create
extremely effective offensive and
defensive quirk combinations just think
about some of the strongest and most
opie quirks out there and then think
about being able to steal those quirks
and combine them all in one person
alternatively the user of all for one
can steal a quirk from one person and
then transfer that quirk to another
person rather than keep it himself the
user wall for one can combine multiple
stolen quirks in order to create more
powerful super kirk's that would never
have occurred naturally and even one for
all itself was actually created by all
for one through the fusing of a powerful
stockpiling quirk and all for one's
brothers quirk transferring quirk back
in Chapter 90 we learned that all four
one can even forcibly activate the
quirks of others as he manually
activates Kudo Gettys quirk warp gate in
order to evacuate shigaraki and the
others before they can be arrested this
could be the result of some other quirk
that all-4-one had stolen but of course
even if this is just the result of a
stolen quirk it still speaks to the
undeniable power of all-4-one and its
quirks stealing ability finally all for
one's ability to transfer stolen quirks
on to other people means that the user
can essentially create his own army of
villains with super-powered combo quirks
all-4-one is able to use his quirk
transferring ability to create the
powerful super soldiers known as the
nomal and in the future he intends to
make already powerful major villains
like shigaraki
even more powerful by giving him
additional quirks some believe that all
for one is planning to transfer to quark
all for one itself to shigaraki although
we are not yet sure whether this is even
possible
personally
I believe that in terms of pure
potential all-4-one might be the single
strongest quirk in boku no hero
just imagine the incredible potential of
being able to steal the quirks of others
combine them to create even more
powerful super kirk's that would never
have occurred naturally and also being
able to create an army of super soldiers
by giving them stolen quirks that they
could never have gotten otherwise as
long as you're willing to act like a
villain and steal the quirks of others
the power you could potentially attain
with all for one is truly immeasurable
but with that said all for one does have
some significant weaknesses one of them
is the quirk one for all which cannot be
stolen by all for one and which was
already used to defeat all for one
himself on two separate occasions in
both of those cases one for all has been
wielded by all might and so all might
has been able to decisively prove that
all for one is not unstoppable and as I
mentioned earlier one weakness of all
for one is the fact that you have to be
kind of amoral and willing to become a
villain in order to use it stealing the
quirks of others against their will and
conducting human experiments is not
exactly what a protagonist would do if I
had to make my choice right now I would
say that while all for one seems to have
more overall potential in terms of being
able to combine different super-powered
quirks and being able to create an army
of super soldiers in practice one for
all has proven to be stronger at this
point in time than all for one this was
not always the case and all for one was
able to kill multiple one for all users
in the past but as of the eighth user
all might one for all seems to have
stockpiled enough power to be able to
defeat all for one and we've seen it
happen two times so far and while we're
talking about the strongest quirks in
boku no hero we cannot forget about a
little quirk called overhaul this
insanely overpowered quirk allows its
user to disintegrate anything he touches
as long as he touches it with at least
one finger he can kill someone instantly
by simply touching them
but the really crazy thing about this
quirk is that if he chooses to
reassemble someone right after
disintegrating them the user of overhaul
can actually bring that person back to
life and he has done this before with
people like rapa the user of this quirk
can control how much of someone's body
is actually disintegrated and if he
chooses not to kill someone but merely
break down parts of their body he can
then reassemble those parts and all of
their past injuries and illnesses within
the body will have been cured imagine
all the good that this quirk could do if
it wasn't wielded by a sociopathic
villain to make things even more
interesting overhaul can also be used on
inorganic materials such as walls and
the ground allowing the user to
potentially disassemble and then
reassemble the entire battlefield in
order to gain an advantage over his
opponent and on top of all of that if he
disassembles parts of his own body at
the same time as parts of someone else's
body the user of overhaul can reassemble
them in a way that essentially fuses the
two people together creating a fused and
more powerful version of himself we can
see this ability on full display during
chiaki's fight against Deku and airy
chisaki the user of overhaul is able to
fuse with two of his underlings on two
separate occasions and we can presume
that while he is fused with another
individual the user of overhaul can make
use of that other person's quirk on top
of his own the quirk overhaul does have
some weaknesses but they are relatively
minor when compared to the quirks
overall power using overhaul seems to
take a physical toll on the user chi-chi
sake develops a rationing as a result of
using the quirk but I'm not sure how
much of this is related to the quirk
itself and how much of it is
psychosomatic since we know that chisaki
suffers from severe germophobia but even
with these minor drawbacks in mind
overhauls ability to destroy and put
back together in organic objects human
bodies and even the user's own body
definitely make this quirk one of the
strongest in boku no hero obviously I'm
talking about the clerk when it was at
the peak of its power because chiaki's
ability to use the quirk is severely
compromised after she got lucky gets his
revenge on the young Yahoo's a leader
all in all I would argue that at the
peak of its power and when used properly
overhaul as a quirk could go toe to toe
with both all-4-one and
one for all this is especially the case
if the user of overhaul is able to make
effective use of the fusing ability if
the user is able to fuse with someone
else who is extremely powerful or if
they are able to potentially fuse with
more than one person the user of
overhaul would have a very good chance
of defeating the most experienced users
of one for all and all for one add their
prime it's hard to say with 100%
certainty who would win because a lot of
it would depend on the specific
circumstances on the battlefield and so
on but as much as I think that both all
for one and one for all are extremely
overpowered I would not bet against
overhaul the only key advantage that all
from one might have over overhaul is the
ability to potentially steal overhaul
itself away from its user something that
the user of one-for-all doesn't have to
worry about since that quirk has to be
given away willingly but again whether
all for one would even get a chance to
steal overhaul before overhauls user
turns the entire battlefield into a
deathtrap is something worth considering
and while we can definitely acknowledge
that deck who was able to defeat
overhaul deck who had the help of Harry
and her incredible overpowered quirk
rewind left to his own devices and
without Ares help it is extremely likely
that deku would have been destroyed by
overhaul now let me know what you guys
think do you agree that one for all all
for one and overhaul are three of the
strongest quirks in boku no hero and
which of these three quirks do you think
is the strongest and why which of them
would you want to have if you could have
any quirk also what other quirks would
you like to see me cover in a future
video if we can get 4000 likes on this
video I will make a part 2 based on your
suggestions if you enjoyed this video
you want to see more and you have to be
new to the channel or you still haven't
subscribed please subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of clicking the bell
and selecting the option that says all
otherwise YouTube's gonna bury our
videos it's just the way it goes
you could also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime out
pro patrons for supporting our work and
making these videos possible with all
the constant
on YouTube patron support is more
important than ever thank you guys so
much
first and foremost a special thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including in
grata Allen Adham the world Steelers the
School Bus
Tyson Kadena acquired respect and Pat a
heffa and I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell drous fitted ala beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt ski on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor Taku Timothy
Vargas Sean dark Joe Stanton jccc waka
Barry Gucci and Jessica Kayla Fong if
you enjoy our videos and you think that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]